now on to our top story a severe drought
continues across the west we are getting
the list of valleys top water wasters
thanks for joining us at six i'm brian
loftis i'm denise valdez so we have the
list for las vegas henderson and north
las vegas and they once again include
some pretty big familiar names and
records some are using even more water
than they did in 2020 sasha loftis joins
us live in studio tonight with the
numbers denise and brian our top
residential water users of 2021 have
stayed pretty steady celebrities casino
moguls and business leaders are once
again using the most records show some
taking even more for their properties
than they did in 2020.
now this as a severe drought continues
across the west
topping the list a property which
records reveal belongs to the prince of
brunei the las vegas valley water
district says this spanish trail
property used more than 13 million
gallons in 2021 that's up from 12
million the year before and over 100
times more than the average home number
two a home which records show belongs to
the adelson family in henderson ebay
founder pierre omidyar comes in first
using 9.3 million gallons last year
number two the greenspun family and
other big names also made the lists
again including steve nguyen phil ruffin
mike tyson dana white the fertitta
family and floyd mayweather
this of course comes as lake mead where
we get 90 percent of our water continues
to reach record low levels coming up
tonight at 11 we'll have a closer look
at our community's top water wasters
including commercial we also have those
full lists on our website eight news now
dot com